headed
what's up pretty insane weekend right
yeah
a lot of money loss
well yeah sort of not really yeah
depending who you are yeah a little
little bit it was scary for a couple
days yeah yeah yeah well ladies and
gentlemen if you aren't aware Silicon
Valley Bank almost went belly up or it
looked like it was going to
and we actually
have
the two guys who drove it into the
ground
ladies and gentlemen welcome Zach and
Waleed guys come on in here
[Applause]
no so why were why were you guys
tweeting about Bank runs and starting a
bank run why did you guys do what did
you guys do I saw your deleted tweet of
last night was a banker
were you afraid again yeah
[Laughter]
after you bro last night
we were joking about how like even
saying it's like my friend was like a
bank run is like an evil spirit it's
like it only you conjure it by just
speaking its name yeah so why'd you do
that yeah
you know I didn't want to encourage a
further Bank Run and now this even
invests using the term right investigate
this man
I hate this man
oh yeah you and your friends are just
casually talking about a bank run and
how evil that word is yeah I mean I did
take out a [__] ton of money but that's
because I'm going to Vegas oh okay yeah
I was just there yeah yeah oh yeah why
were you there yeah why were you there
huh yeah
I had a place a 62 Billion Dollar Bet
damn excuse me 167 Billion Dollar Bet
driving that in a tux yeah dude that was
a badass slots run yeah dude yeah no I
am oh siva's wedding oh nice congrats
how was that you got married in Vegas
yeah who's Siva oh yes nice Alina's sea
of these nuts fit in your mouth
Zach go ahead follow your phone call
your parents that sucks
I I have something tell him to buy a
shovel
and a plot I haven't heard one of those
in silver kids I've never gotten someone
and the thing is siva's Siva is an
actual person though yeah so it doesn't
really count it sounded like a real name
anyways this is uh this is for you
thanks
friends
joke I would make you something but you
always keep throwing it behind you you
really just gave him something yeah oh
hell yeah dude
can I see read the bottom text
s nice pretty good
I like it everyone's like what's the
no I do like it thank you ever made that
today just cuz I was like well might as
well
I didn't have time to make yours yeah
yeah cool thanks I'll see who you like
more oh yeah
damn it damn bro
um so anyone lose money this weekend no
I'm I was saying I was afraid of Bank of
America going down no wait even better
so I walk in and
uh I compromise the excerpt I said man I
like the [__] outfit good outfit all
around all around great job boys yeah I
know so then
well no hold on while Lee walks in he
goes he looks nice right I say yeah and
then Zach says no you were you were
talking [__] what are you talking about
well he said no I said you were balding
show your head I was betting it's okay
it's pretty bad Rachel I don't think
you're thank you you definitely are
I was bending over because he said he
can tuck in your shoelace or your your
tongues of your shoes because he was
also dissing that part of my outfit yeah
so I was bending over to [__] tuck it
in and he goes oh damn you're balding
too dude I was like Jesus
[__] quite the stars that that is
like
I don't know that's up there with like
these nuts a bit Yeah well dude you
could tuck your tongue into your shoe
hey what's on the [__] back your head
oh we have nothing yeah
no I'm definitely I'm dead you know
things are happening yeah would you get
the surgery in Turkey would I get it
yeah yeah I would get it he's not even
close to getting it though yeah but you
have to be proactive in that little yes
yeah I heard you were you're doing
physical therapy yeah
hair up
it's not a hair in her hair that's why
it's going away dude [__] you keep
pulling my exercises yeah we didn't know
that does chlorine affect it and like
[__] like that no I don't think so I
mean I'd like spend my life in a pool
yeah so that was that what your hair was
yelling no but it does do that though
yeah it like makes your hair green yeah
that's sick remember we're like I don't
know when you're younger you never do
like kids on the swim team no what no
like kids were like like bleach their
hair and then the chlorine would make it
green oh damn this looks stupid as hell
were they make your pubic hair itch
hello
no because every time I hung out
like I'm the pool and I came out these
like little things
that it was on fire I'm like that's the
chlorine right like they have like all
that Peebles too right
no there's chlorine so all my swimmer
boys always have a few bites my hometown
friends are are water polo boys and they
always have their hands in their pants
and were like itching and [__]
I thought that was normal they have a
problem
yeah maybe it was because
[__] boys you guys are crazy you guys
are awesome good to see you
actually
[Laughter]
damn guess it's not normal yeah there
was someone on the stream who called we
did the voicemail thing
and they were like
can you please uh ask Cody something and
I was like yeah for sure he's like can
you tell him to talk about diving more
okay it was it was so sentimental he was
so worried
he's like what do you want to know I
don't know he's just like you know he's
just not really showing out for the
diving Community is he a diver I don't
know
okay yeah or he's just a big fan yeah
there's not a lot of fans yeah yeah he's
like please yeah indulge ask me
something when was the last time
the last time I dove was senior year of
college like right before I graduated it
was zones did you know it was your last
dive yeah I did
I knew it
yeah middle fingers up no was it
emotional yeah it definitely was dang
yeah like but it was also kind of like a
H like done with this leaving it like it
was kind of nice like you know so you
did do double Birds I kind of I kind of
did like mentally oh okay I was flipping
the bird right nice did you hang under
the water and wipe tears so like you
know I didn't cry okay no let's try to
hide but it was emotional like you do
something for 12 years
like it like consumed my life for 12
years and then you're like okay that
chapter is over that's a little the one
guy who's watching this yeah yeah yeah
you stood up for the diving community
long ass comments you know dude when I
asked you to talk about diving I didn't
ask you to [__] on it like that
dang okay honest question about running
then because you said you're also the
physical therapist working on your knees
yeah right are you worried about like
the longer you're running and the more
you're doing it like like isn't it gonna
affect you when you get older exactly
did you leave the voicemail
you're also not standing up for the
running community
no I talk about running a lot are you
scared are you scared about your knees
about my knees no I it freaks me out
that everyone always says that like
while you're when you get older it's a
common yeah I thought it's like a
comment like my parents have been doing
it for like 30 years and they're the
fittest people I know yeah by the time
future like you know they'll have metal
kneecaps and [__] and I don't want that
Elon Musk will figure some [__] out it
was really weird your parents were
crawling around your whole wedding
though that was odd
no they actually have entirely metal
yeah they're like kind of cyborgs
mom's walking me down the aisles
but that's not very good robotics yeah
yeah okay it's just hella slow then she
got like permanent Heelys in it's just
the other day did you ever wear Heelys
and I said yeah but without the wheels
she's like so you just warm her up
they brought back soap shoes recently
what is that I don't know that they had
like the grind
uh like the little pad in the center of
the shoe so you could grind oh you're
like so dangerous yeah yeah at least my
ass
crack my head open and die oh that you
would do that because you're balding
yeah
surgery I'm gonna go to Turkey I'm gonna
do it and just get him I'll get them
yeah I'll get them from my neck or from
I heard it doesn't work though they just
pull hair from somewhere else
probably no yeah
from your pubes then you're itchy all
the time
it just looks like Sprouts in the middle
of his head he has a bleach spot just
like one random straight hair
the [__] is that past that's a water
polo dude because we're not too like yo
let me put my hand on yeah
oh it looks itchy yeah no never I'll
never worried because I have so much
hair in my ass that I'll know that I'll
cover my whole head yeah me too yeah
it's really bad it's really bad yeah
it's like a monkey down there yeah yeah
you guys going for like a two for one
they could take out like a full acre out
of my ass and you know how like when
people get hair plugs you can see that
line they get the scar yeah they could
they could do as much as they wanted
down there No One's Gonna know you ever
see those uh No One's Gonna Be able to
tell those photos where they're like the
flights back from Turkey
is so funny yeah I thought you could say
laying on your stomach like a BBL
because they took all the hair out of
your ass